you guys like writing on the card all
right guys come on hop off here Andrew
[Music]
oh oh there's a monkey on my bag okay
guys right yeah you want to go swimming
or eat pizza
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so tell me you like your transformer bed
really just form my grasp
dubov road to rescue yeah it's a it's a
couch and then it goes there becomes a
bed you guys are having fun tell you you
have a good to get machine all right
yeah okay oh yeah we go where we go do
little breakfast oh man down you're
watching this grab a table with simply
do you think you like your waffle Tommy
like your waffle yeah I love you making
fun of your conference before Thank You
sis you can't come sorry yeah hey I get
to meet ya cream corn all right hold
that Tom come on guys all right Tom
nation come on what yeah let's get you
in
[Music]
[Applause]
no I don't see any car but I know
there's carp in this river and this is a
car P looking clot oh hey guys do you
want to see something come here look at
this right there that's that's a raccoon
print that's that's from the raccoon pan
the mud okay
- and little claws okay
oh yeah well let's get some lunch keep
looking for spots
you guys having good food you like the
milkshake oh no boot
Tommy would you could you grab something
like area fishing rod that would help Oh
we'll get to you
you're strong Nathan yeah let me help
you with that
good job buddy all right
Wow I think we're gonna get pretty muddy
Keith yeah you guys are playing in the
mud yeah that's a nice bunker it's good
Janis good for bunkin salmon ah
you're stuck you need help you're
getting really muddy yeah
you're giving me Muddy Buddy okay really
take the pieces missing
all right you Dylan Phyllis gonna hold
on okay I am shocked we actually caught
anything listen I said it was pretty
good size little fish yeah you totally
fell in the water yeah well that's why
we put you in a life vest and stay close
to Daddy well look at this well here get
to that I need the net ah come on you
had your turn you get another turn yeah
hold on you gotta throw them in there we
go you go you ready
Oh Tommy pick them up pick him up he's
on he's on you got them pick him up you
know I called these a little sucker or
chub I think this is actually a fall
fish hey time you let me go sorry buddy
everyone amazing hey hold it okay
raised it up really high I going that
house yeah yeah okay we got it we got to
go put them back okay there Nathan put
them back hey Weez off around the bend
- curtain keep going I got up dumb woo
here
Oh good-sized one but he's not this is
your last one all right Wow there you go
I fit into watch so on yeah giving him a
nice break so you keep them in the net
here recharge that hold them they think
you got him - okay okay ready put them
back in the water if you guys want to go
home do you want to go home
yeah blaze in the mud
well we are pretty dirty soon we gonna
get back come on you got it flaunt it
Tom yeah how we store our children at
night
Nathan's passed out more hotel bathrooms
in our Rockstar Ruby do get to thank you
[Music]
are you guys ready to go do some more
fishing all right let's do it a rock
[Applause]
grab pick it up
you got anybody
that's a serious one
[Music]
Nathan Nathan you're in Milan [ __ ]
Nathan Nathan you just be over there
that's where we're going desiccation
deep
all right over here - Stephen take the
net get him you got him there you go
David you got him you did it all right
these river fish sure are strong they uh
they pull pound for pound harder than
Lake Cartman let's get it back in town
give him a place you live two three push
[Music]
all right I hope yeah well I don't need
this yeah don't let him get around that
corner
[Music]
hit the upper ticket job okay ready
the grandmas love side you like that
padded it up analogy that already know
you got him
you should blue looks another big fish
the car for just Parker's look it up
[Music]
Wow so next I'm Ralph he'll make
sandwiches oh yeah that's the stuff
right there oh yeah steps we apply our
daily canteen appliers Erica all right
there you go there's a sandwich for you
and I sandwich for you
Nathan you're happy good
you having fun Tommy yeah I like
climbing trees come on yeah I got a fish
one you met him okay let's go get the
next yeah I know that's why I'm telling
you to come over here it's going to hurt
you come over here where you're not
going to get hurt yeah those are
stinging nettles and not fun well we've
got some lovely fish on this trip it's
been awesome but both the boys here have
experienced stinging nettles we're going
to go take them home is that where it
hurts Tommy yeah Nathan yeah Nathan just
threw my GoPro on the LA River
oh yeah take care of my hand okay like
your eyes
all right pause Oh baby you have a good
trip
thank you
you have a good trip hey thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
if you want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel click like
subscribe we put out new videos every
week thanks for watching Tommy are you
having a good time fishing yes